I want to thank the organizers very much
for inviting me to talk on my very
favorite subject the evolution of
evolvability
so um I have just three uh U miror goals
for this talk one is to review the early
work on the evolution of evolvability
two to dispel the myth that it requires
group selection of course Joanna's talk
already did that for me but I'll
elaborate on it and number three
describe one mechanism for the evolution
of evolvability due to individual
selection so first I want to delve into
sort of how I think about evolutionary
computation evolutionary algorithms and
you have this you have some
representation of your problem space and
then you have operators that act act on
that representation you know such as a
bit string or real valued vector or
whatever and the interaction of those
two produces this transmission function
that says given parents eye J and K what
is the probability that The Offspring is
of type I and it's the relationship
between this transmission function and a
fitness function that determines the
performance of the
algorithm so here's an example of a of a
of a problem that has been cast for
evolutionary algorithms massive
multimodality where uh you're trying to
find the very fittest of all these peaks
in this function here's the the specific
function and uh problem is that if you
you start it um The evolutionary
algorithm it'll tend to find one of
these Peaks and not find the global
Optimum and so here's the this is the
function you have this mutation acting
on it and you can this is a real value
Vector so these are distributed this is
Gan
distribution now there's no reason that
the representation of that function has
to be the natural one you can rewrite
the representation in terms of the phase
and the wave number and this with these
change of variables and with these
details and now in terms of the the wave
number and the phase you plot the
fitness function and now it's pretty
smooth you know it's basically has has
one mode with a little off on the side
there and this is quite easy to do to
solve with this representation now
alternatively that's equivalent to a
change in the mutation operator where
instead of mutating it like this you
mutate it like this where you have now a
little Epsilon and then and a
perturbation of the wave number
similarly for the for the Y value that
will produce the same landscape and also
be easy to solve with
a a hill climber so um there's in a
sense an operator representation duality
that changes in representations may be
equivalent to changes in genetic
operators in producing the same new
transmission function this probability
that a j and a k produce an
I so now I'm going to look at a
particular
example from genetic programming where
you actually have here's a function
that's represented as a parse Tree on
variables and operators and you take two
different equations two different
functions and you take a chunk of each
of them and Rec combine them to produce
this Offspring it looks like this so um
genetic programming is very interesting
because it's not a fixed cardinality of
the space it's basically open-ended and
can you say what these diagrams have to
do with these gaussian functions that's
this so if you here's a x mu Sigma 2
that's Sigma to the squared power Sor
okay so this tree produces that function
the graph is the the proing of the of
the function what is the over
these so so that's these are binary
operators that's xus
mu mu there okay I see and then the
power Operator 2 x - mu^ 2 so this
little tree is that function I mean this
is a representation of that function and
this is a representation of that
function and then you have an
operator and by recombining these two
sub trees you get this and that happens
to be this
function
you look what's the
question how how did I get this yeah or
yeah this assume any Distribution on the
V well so the the subtree recombination
operator which is standard used in
genetic programming it picks a node here
and takes that whole subtree of the
node and it picks a node on this program
and
and it swaps these two things together
and so here here is this
node uh down here okay so it put this
node into that position so this is this
part is the donor here and this part is
the uh injected onto
here and so basically so you have here's
the space of functions and then you
produce a baby function from it with
some
ability and this is what it looks like
and so this is the this is the technique
of genetic programming so um where these
are all executable structures
essentially and here's an extremely
interesting early result from nordon and
bons off they looked at the fitness
distribution of these recombination
operators and they started out
generation zero and you see look there's
that bimodality that Joanna talked about
this is an completely different context
is so here's zero no Fitness change
after crossover and there's a peak there
so what's the definition of Fitness here
uh so okay um you have you know you have
some ideal
function as uh uh less valant talked
about and you want to see how close as
you input different values of these
terminals X mu and sigma uh you want to
see how close to the ideal function this
function is and that closeness is your
Fitness okay so you're you're trying to
evolve say you're trying to evolve the
gine distribution through this process
or and it produces these things so um so
the closeness of this function define
over some set of inputs to an idealized
function that's your Fitness and so
um now so here this is a plot looking at
the fitness change after crossover so
you start out something it's probably
not very good as far as your ideal
function but you're looking at what kind
of change what's the distribution of
Fitness
effects from the recombination operator
acting on this population and you see
here's a neutral a big peak at
neutrality and there's a little bit of
ADV Advantage a little bit of mild delar
and and a big peak at leth lethality you
know that don't that are very far off
and as this population evolves under
selection and this operator this
recombination you see this neutrality
Peak grow and grow and grow and grow and
The lethality gets starting to get
smaller and so something is happening
here with this distribution of Fitness
effects of recombination as the
population evolves and it seems to be it
seems to be increasing the mut the
recombinational
robustness question yes ah sorry uh
hiding behind you so are they
controlling for the diversity in the
population here because if the
population was gen gentically converged
then all the Crossovers would be neutral
oh no that's not true no that's not true
even if you were crossing over with
yourself be non- neutral yeah so genetic
programming with these trees the sub
trees can generate complexity even if
you have just a single one in the
population yeah okay yeah
so something is going
on in the way in the way this program is
evolving such that the fitness
distribution of these combination events
is
changing and um and it's something in
the way that these trees are
representing the functions such that
when you recombine them you're getting
more and more
neutrality and so this is a very
intriguing phenomenon and and the fact
that you get this B modality um I think
is extremely uh deep property that um
merits further investigation
so here I'm going to Tre to get bigger
yes yeah another there's all sorts of
interesting you know called War Stories
from genetic programming you're trying
to evolve something and something else
happens so bloat is one of the immediate
immediate discoveries of genetic
programming that the programs get bigger
and bigger and there's a variety of
explanations but there's not you know
there's still theoretical work to be
done on that yes was your population
starting with the ideal function no they
just start you know with a random
collection of trees and nodes and start
doing the operators on them and
selecting
them
so
um this is a this is a great quote by
Jeffrey Levon which I I consider my Call
to Arms it kind of summarizes the theme
of of basically most of my research and
um and it's from the first edition of
this book he deleted it from the second
edition I don't know why but
evolutionary biologists have been mainly
concerned with the fate of variability
in populations not the generation of
variability the genetic and epigenetic
factors that to generate variability
have received relatively little
attention this could stem from the
dominance of population genetic thinking
or it may be due to a general ignorance
of the mechanistic connections between
the genes and the phenotype whatever the
reason the time has come to reemphasize
the study of the origin of variation and
so the evolution evolvability is
precisely one of the subjects among the
study of the origin of
variation so I want to talk about the
origins of of this concept
uh it actually goes under different
names goes back at least to Rupert rle
in a book uh from
1975 um and uh where he refers to it as
the increase in the probability of a
successful adaptation and then Michael
Conrad in a series of papers used
different terms to refer to it the
efficiency efficient evolutionary
Behavior increase evolutionary
amenability and then the self
facilitation of
evolution so Dawkins in this
uh paper in the book of First artificial
life book um coined the catchy phrase
evolution of evolvability and
subsequently this phrase was adopted by
several researchers working in the area
but using other
terms and um so here's a little Google
search showing the mention of the
evolution of evolvability as it's
changed in time so here's where Dawkins
wrote his paper and there you can see
it's it's tremendous tremendously
growing the Baseline graph of papers per
year
period oh very good very good point very
good point yeah how do I do that
um I can assure you it wasn't zero in
1988 so um so now there's over 120
papers per year that refer refer to the
evolution of evolvability and there's
many ideas and mechanisms that now
populate this phrase and I'm I won't
attempt here you're claiming the number
of ideas that's gone I hope so um that's
an empirical question I think deserves
study
um I yes I yes I think so um and I'm not
going to attempt to review the whole
field um but I want to describe one
specific mechanism which is the role of
Gene origin in the evolution of
evolvability and I won't even make
claims about its relative importance
that's an empirical question but I want
to show at least how different phenomena
are connected
theoretically so let's begin with Dawkin
paper anathema he calls it a title like
the evolution of evolvability ought to
be anathema to a died in the wool
radical Neo darwinian like me but he
describes this idea he says as the ages
go by GE you know geologic ages changes
in embryology that increase evolutionary
richness tend to be self-perpetuating
I'm talking about a kind of higher level
selection a selection not for
survivability but for evolvability it
now seems to me that an embryology that
is pregnant with evolutionary potential
is a good candidate for a higher level
property of just the kind that we must
have before we allow ourselves to speak
of species or higher level of
selection
so right away Michael Conrad who'd been
working in this area wrote in this paper
the geometry of
evolution u a kind of a reply he says
let us now Recall why the concept of
evolvability is controversial some
evolutionists argue that natural
selection can act only on properties
that are advantageous to the individual
evolvability is advantageous to the
species do not therefore let the concept
of evolvability mix into biological
thinking so he says Conrad continues
this dictum is wrong on two counts first
some mutation buffering redundancies are
in fact advantageous to the individual
organism so this this mutation that
buffers redundancies is Conrad's
mechanism Chief mechanism for the
evolution of evolvability a a creation
smoothing the Adaptive landscape anyway
he says some of these redundancies are
in fact advantageous to the individual
organism they confer stability of the
phenotypic Dynamics and serve to buffer
the change the effect of genetic change
so that's mutational robustness and that
this buffering and other EV Evolution
facilitating mechanisms can accumulate
even if they are attacks from the
standpoint of the individual organism
when they occur the evolution
facilitating redundancies will hitchhike
along with the advantageous traits whose
appearance they facilitate so I'm not
going to belabor Conrad's
mechanism um but it's clearly an
individual based not a population-based
property now I'm going to show several
subsequent papers that you know that
don't acknowledge
this mechanism and um and continue to
maintain that it's a controversial idea
I guess I'm confused why does one need a
mechanism at all I mean it's all just
the fact that you conditioned on things
we see of inly successful so they like
the look evolable I've looked as if they
were evolable well you've just described
a mechanism that's a mechanism that's
just general statement I mean what is a
mechanism a a theoretical relationship I
mean
uh
that explains why something is there
instead of not there your statement
applies to all adaptations why does it
look adapted because it it only survived
because it was
adapted I
mean so I don't I guess I don't see why
one needs an explanation well I
mean it's the classic evolution of sex
problem that was discussed by fiser
which should be up there actually 1930
which is why do organisms have sex but
well current understanding is that sex
is actually disadvantageous to an
individual as we understand it although
there's some special explanation but
people said what it's good for the
population it is populations that have
sexual recombination and
sexual systemtic system can evolve more
rapidly and therefore populations that
have sexual reproduction as opposed to
asexual population the sexual population
will out compete the asexual population
over a long period of time so therefore
or the explanation for why populations
have sex is a question of avability
well that's but this is one always can
go backwards and make explanations bi
don't have to Beal explanations all
biologists do sorry that's all the
biologists do that's okay well
so the question of which things need
explaining and which things don't right
and the so do you think that why someone
have sex is an interesting
question question but doesn't need
explaining I that's a yes or no question
is that an interesting question yes or
no this good for the discussion yeah but
it's a fundamental
misconception you can say no let me just
point out that the mechanism you
described that fiser gave this sort of
the background thinking of why the what
evolvability is a population level
phenomenon rather than individual level
because that explanation of the
evolution of sexual reproduction is you
know you said one species versus another
so that would be in in this class that
these people are claiming is necessary
to explain the evolution of evolvability
so here's the snowski and Murphy because
populations not individuals evolve and
adapt it follows that evolvability as
adaptation must be the consequence of
selection among populations rather than
selection among individuals selection
among populations is possible in
principle but is a very weak force
compared with individual level
selections here again Michael Lynch says
first evolution is a population level
feature thus if an organismal feature
that modifies the ability to evolve is
to advance to be Advanced directly by ad
adaptive mechanism selection must
operate efficiently at a higher level of
organization than the individual this
requires a significantly subdivided
population structure with levels of
evolvability being positively correlated
with population longevity and or
productivity because population survive
longer than individuals such group
selection is expected to be a much
weaker Force an individual selection Etc
and then uh another one uh from 2011 one
of the reasons that the concept
evolvability is controversial is that
models of evolvability usually invoke
levels of selection above the individual
because natural selection lacks
foresight and tends to fix alals that
maximize current Fitness regardless of
the consequences for future evolutionary
potential of the population evolvability
is generally not expected to be selected
at the level of individuals
and finally one last quote the
hypothesis that differences in
evolvability result from past natural
selection acting on the ability to
evolve however remains highly
controversial for two primary reasons
evolvability is a population level
phenotype and thus must be favored by
the relatively weak forces generated by
natural selection at the population
level and um so selection on
evolvability suggests the unlikely
scenario that natural selection has the
evolutionary foresight to adapt a
popular to Future environmental
contingencies so despite the early
literature explaining how individual
selection can act on evolvability the
myth persists that group selection is
required so here's the the the
definition of evolvability that I'm
going to be using throughout is the
probability that an organism generates
adaptive genetic variation so in other
words Offspring with higher Fitness than
the parents this is this is clearly not
a population property but a property of
organisms it's the upper tail of the
fitness distribution of an organism's
Offspring this evolvability then is a
subproperty of the distribution of
Fitness effects of genetic
variation so here's a lovely graph um
and um oops sorry I it's
finberg uh at all I left that off there
so here's a distribution of Fitness
effects from mutation the log of the
distribution here's that bimodality that
Joanna talked about and um you know
these are so low that these could all be
lumped in together to one load so you
can divide it into three parts the the
the deleterious mutations are the
genetic load the neutral mutations are
this mutational robustness and then the
Adaptive mutations are the evolvability
as I'm calling it so here's a this
distribution of Fitness effects is
another phrase that has come into
increasingly uh growing use and it's
here compared with the evolution of
evolvability and you can see it it took
off about uh looks like about 5 years
later and it's growing Great Guns is
actually beating it now so we need to
work on that but here's the interesting
thing um the intersection of papers that
use both these
phrases is very very small and I I
advise everybody to read these 36 papers
um so I I think one goal of future work
is to get these two communities talking
to each
other so now this evolvability as a
distribution of Fitness effects so um
it's a well-known entity and as you
mention fiser it's great how many you
know it's reading fiser he he's amazing
guy and he he he just touches on some
subjects but way before anybody else did
and so he has this geometric argument
about the probability of producing an
advantageous mutation and so this is a
you imagine this is a cont Fitness
Contour in some you know High
dimensional space and uh the closer you
are to the center the fitter you are and
so he's imagining you know in the
genotype evolving producing these
phenotypes and then getting closer and
closer to the center but if you think
about the mutation distribution around
each point you know it's kind of a ball
here and as you get closer and closer to
the center
a smaller and smaller fraction of that
ball lies inside the part that's still
fitter so it's kind of a generic idea
that's as you know that's uh goes back
to the 30s that the evolvability as this
upper tail of the fitness distribution
should go down as adaptive Evolution
takes you to some adaptive
Peak
so
now I want to talk about what's really
the the earliest appearance of the
mechanism I want to describe uh that I
found in the literature which is Rupert
rle and um I want to quote rid's
argument here so he says what would
happen if independent genetic units um
the structural results of which have
become functionally dependent were also
to become epigenetically dependent for
example by adopting superimposed genetic
unit upon which both are dependent as in
the case of two structural genes
dependent on an operator
Gene well the answer is the mutation of
of only one genetic unit the operator
will result in the change of both if the
probability of mutation and the
probability of success of a superimposed
gene do not differ greatly from those of
structural genes and the chance of a
successful alteration would rise from
this product Square to just this product
so this is if you have to change two
genes to produce an advantage versus now
you only have to produce change one gene
to produce an advantage in other words
from 10us 12 to 10- 6 that would
increase as much as a
millionfold so such a millionfold
increase in the Adaptive chances can
therefore be achieved if the unnecessary
genetically redundant or risky
Independence or adaptive freedom of a
single genetic unit is avoided by
expedient
dependency such adaptive advantages by
syst imization that's his term are so
tremendous that the invention of a
superimposed genetic unit must be
expected even if it would be a
millionfold or trillion fold more
unlikely than every other alteration
within the genome if the system like the
operon were not known to exist we could
have predicted that it must
exist so the chances of successful
adaptation increase if genetic units by
insertion of superimposed genes copy the
functional dependencies of those fiend
structures for which they code
this positive feedback of the Adaptive
speed or probability that is
evolvability within a single adaptive
direction is compensated by negative
feedback in most of the alter
alternative directions that is
mutational robustness in modern
parlaments
so that is a rudimentary form of the
idea that I want to try to describe so
different genetic transformation each
have their own distribution of Fitness
effects you know for each particular Al
Gene there's alic mutations deletions
recombination Gene duplications denovo
Gene origin Etc so here I'm going to be
concerned chiefly with one alic
mutations and four and five Gene Origins
and the relationship between
them so let's go back to this
distribution again what determines the
distribution of Fitness effects of
mutation or of Gene
duplication well adaptive opportunity
due to current imperfection or
environmental change and then
probability of improving these imperfect
functions while not disturbing adapted
functions so the way that genetic
variation maps to pH phenotypic
variation is fundamental to whether or
not that variation has the possibility
of producing adaptive change so even
when a strong opportunity
exists um for new for new adaptations
many of the previously evolved functions
will remain under stabilizing selection
adaptive adaptation requires the
variation to be able to move the
organismal phenotype towards traits
under directional selection without
greatly disturbing traits remaining
under stabilizing selection so variation
that disturbs existing adaptations as it
produces new adaptations that is
variation which is plot Tropic will have
difficulty producing an overall fitness
advantage
so here's the the basic idea if you
think
about all the genes in the genome having
a kind of tournament about who gets to
produce the next Gene in the genome and
you know randomly different copies are
produced if some subset of them because
of the nature of their phenotypic action
have a higher chance of being producing
a fitness advantage those are the ones
that you're going to see in the genome
that's where genome growth is going to
occur is based on that subset based on
their probability of producing a fitness
advantage
and so
um but here's the interesting thing so
selection during the origin of genes it
provides a filter on the construction of
the genotype phenotype map which
naturally produces evolvability
so when a gene duplication is retained
by The genome two things are changed
first is the probability of a leic
variation in that Gene family is
increased just because there's more of
that Gene family and second the
probability of subsequent Gene
duplication of that Gene family is also
increased
so the the probability that a gene
duplication goes to fixation of the
population is a strongly increasing
function of the fitness effect of its
creation and different distributions of
Fitness effects among all the possib
gene duplications in the genome means
that new genes are enriched with those
that have fat upper Fitness
Tails creation of a new Gene not only
produces its current phenotypic effect
but carries with a new neighborhood in
sequence space the kinds of variants
that it can in turn give rise to both
alic and subsequent
duplicates so here's the idea you have a
gene sequence and then some duplication
of it is made in the genome and it has
some probability of different Fitness
effects and then from that you now it
can produce subsequent alic variation or
it can be in turn copied for another
Gene duplication event and so selection
on who gets to survive in the genome can
change the distribution of Fitness
effects for these two subsequent events
and that's the core idea here and that's
basically the the essence of what rert
rle is talking
about
so because a Gene's creation and its
subsequent duplication and AIC
diversification are most likely to be
acting on the same set of organismal
functions the distribution of Fitness
effects should be related between these
three events a Gene's creation the
subsequent alic variation of the Gene
and subsequent dup duplications of the
gene thus the very fact of a Gene's
existence is a condition that biases the
distribution of Fitness effects of a
Gene's alic variation and subsequent
duplication so item a I claim that on
first principles um but the it's the
magnitude of that relationship that's
the principal determinant of this
mechanism and it requires empirical
quantification so the prevalence of Gene
duplication here's a re very recent
paper uh or no not this is from 2003 by
ji showing uh the number of duplicate uh
genes as and the percent of that are
duplicate genes in um various species
here and it's not
insignificant so it's it's a mechanism
it's it's a part of the evolutionary
Gish this is duplicate where you can
what's the definition of dup so okay
that's a very good question how do you
know it's duplicate you can you know
once it's once there are two different
genes independently evolving the primary
sequence the nucleotide sequence or the
amino acid sequence can diverge and so
the longer that that they've been
diverging the harder it is to tell that
one is actually a copy of the other so
you can only go back so far back in time
depending on the gene you know like RNA
you know RNA genes you can go back
hundreds of millions of years but other
genes it's more difficult so um you know
there's kind of a
cloud a fog where you where you
disappear where where you know whether
two genes
are are duplicates or not or whether
parts of them came from somewhere else
but at least on shorter time scales you
can document that and there's plenty of
the literature is full of different
cases of trees showing Gene
duplications so
um now I want
to as an
illustration let's go to the extreme end
and suppose that this property that this
distribution of Fitness effects of a
Gene's creation and its subsequent
duplications is identical it's perfectly
inherited from one gene copy to the next
so um let's see under that assumption
what
happens so here's a model we suppose
that the the change in a gene number in
per unit time is equal to the
probability that it duplicates that it
fixes in the population and that it is
maintained by selection times the number
of genes at a given time and so the
probability that it fixes is equal to
this integral
that for a gene of type I and there's a
probability distribution density over
Fitness is W that it has and then this
is kind of this is your genetic drift
function that says given the probability
of uh given a certain Fitness what's the
probability that it goes to fixation so
clearly a small the smaller the
population um there's more probability
fixation even for a Del slightly
delerious G but anyway I don't delve
into that any more deeply so
um so if we let um so let let Alpha be
just the probability that I duplicates
and then this beta aide the probability
that it fixes and is maintained in the
genome then the Dynamics of Gene
expansion are then this D this
differential equation very simple which
has this
exponential um
solution and it's exponential in this
beta sub
property which is the property that the
gene fixes and is maintained in the
genome by selection so what happens U
let's for concreteness suppose that the
initial distribution is a gan
distribution and um then we get this
time trajectory and here's I'll graph it
now so suppose we start with a genome of
700 genes and here's a distribution of
this beta value this is the so this is
basically the success probability of a
duplication in becoming stable
Incorporated in the genome and then you
let the genome grow and in time that you
this this distribution shifts when you
have 3700 genes it's shifted up here and
here by the time you get to the size of
a human genome um the bulk of the
population is up way up here in values
that were scarcely evident um early on
in its Evolution so what we are seeing
here is an evolu shift to increase the
probability that a new useful Gene is
kept by The genome so that's the
evolution of evolvability in a positive
direction now um
so if we we can make a little theorem
out of this and it's basically Fisher's
theorem fundamental theorem applied to
genome growth that the if you assume
that this beta I probability is
perfectly transmitted between Gene
duplications then the fraction of new
duplicate genes that go to fixation and
are maintained this beta bar which is
the sum of this increases at this rate
which is proportional to the variance in
beta subi which will be greater than
zero so um basically this says that the
evolution with this perfect transmission
evolvability will increase through this
Gene duplication process and there's the
details of the calculation
so now to be a little bit more realistic
suppose that there's less than perfect
heritability of this beta sub I and then
you have some transmission function
where J produces an i with some
probability T and then um you know so
they sum to one they're all positive so
then the fraction of new genes that are
of type I is just this simple
average and then the genome expansion
Dynamics become this
and here we can invoke Price's
covariance and selection equation and um
for this arbitrary transmission and we
get this relationship that now the
change in time of this this probability
the new that a new Gene produces an
advantage is equal to these terms so
here's basically the difference these uh
these averages that difference there is
the effect of gene duplic the kind of
the um secular effect the bias that it
has on the probability so if uh if it
pushes it down then this is negative
rate but here you have this covariance
between this C subj is the probability
that not that uh you basically not that
your Offspring genes are kept by The
genome but basically that your grand
offspring are kept by The
genome and uh if the co-variance between
your grand Offspring and your Offspring
probabilities of of uh incorporation are
positive then this rate of change
basically then evolvability will evolve
in a positive direction so this is a
very general relationship for kind of an
arbitrary
transmission uh of uh arbitrary change
in the in these probabilities between a
gene and its duplications
so this
covariance if that's positive that
produces a increase in evolvability
now if it's not evident at this point we
are here talking about a basically a
kind of darwinian evolution at the level
of the genome as a population so one of
the the requirements for darwini
evolution is heritable variation and
fitness and this actually emerges in
this genome as a population of genes so
here
viability is simply the survival of a
sequence in the genome and it depends on
whether selection establishes it and
maintains
it uh and this this in turn depends on
the Adaptive opportunity and the uh the
sequence having functional properties
which are not disrupted by new
functional contexts and also the
sequence having properties that allow
its duplication without duplicate
without disrupting existing functions of
genes with which it
interacts um so uh facundity here is the
rate simply the rate at which a gene is
copied by all the genetic processes of
the
genome and uh so transposable elements
would have be very high in this fund
property but not very high in the
viability because they tend to get
eliminated rather
quickly and then heritability in this
genome as population refers to ancestral
and Offspring genes having correlated
properties so the conservation of the
property of a gene overtime scale on
which the duplication occurs and then a
carryover of the property from ancestral
to offspring
genes so um I want to look at some
illustrations of this in computational
experiments and uh having a very simple
model of of this genome growth process
where you have you add a new Gene to the
genome you look at its functional effect
or you basically you randomly sample its
functional effects from this some random
underlying distribution and then if the
new Gene produces a fitness decrease you
reject it if the gene produces a fitness
increase you keep it and then you adapt
it through a lelix substitution till
it's at a fitness Peak and then you go
back to the beginning and that's how
your genome grows so a lot of you know a
lot of these samples that are that don't
help Fitness are simply tossed away and
you only keep them if they keep the Gene
and its functional effects if it
improves Fitness uh
immediately so basically these are the
population assumptions that would
justify this
algorithm so
um uh let me
uh so uh in short Ono talks
about uh that when you have a gene
duplication you have now have a
redundant uh Gene in the genome that's
basically neutral however here's a just
a a chart showing various human diseases
caused by Gene duplications so it's not
a it's not a fundamental property that a
gene duplication is neutral here are
many ones that are delerious so the
question is so here's a prediction if
this if the dist distribtion of Fitness
effects of duplication is generally
heritable between duplications then
genes that produce delerious
duplications for example these disease
genes ought to have either a higher than
average rates of duplication or fewer
and older paralogs than average over the
genome so that that's a prediction based
on this this framework so again we we
want to look at at relationships between
these so that that model of genome
growth was basically looking at the
relationship between a and B now I want
to look at the relationship between a
and C between a a gene that's fixed when
it's duplicated and a subsequent alic
variation so
um what we're going to do is um so
here's how selection on the creation of
new genes can cause subsequent alic
variation of the genes to be more likely
to be adaptive so you look at the
fitness distribution of Al from all new
genes and then look at them compare that
with the ones that are sta in
Incorporated in the
genome uh let's
see I'm going to
skip this which is basically another
form of this covariance relationship
which says if there's a covariance
between the fitness distribution of a
gene and the probability that the gene
uh was created the fit instiution of a
leic variance then you get this
that the the the alals generated by
genes that are stable Incorporated in
the genome are going to have a higher
upper tail than the random ones created
by all possible Gene
duplications uh let
me so let me
show illustration with two concrete
models and the first one is this B
matrix model of gter Vagner so you have
a this is a a genotype that's a real
valued vector and you have a linear map
to this phenotype space and then you
have a phenotypic Optimum and then this
Q
Matrix uh defines
how how being away from this Optimum
decreases your Fitness so here's the
explicit uh
relationship and uh and now what you
want to do is you add a new column to
this to this Matrix a that again that
Maps you from genotype to phenotype so
you add a new column to this Matrix a
and uh to yield a new Matrix and you
want to know if if look at the change in
the fitness so the new fitness will be
of this value so here's the new column
of Gene effects from the new Gene X subn
plus one and this is the new fitness and
you you basically you keep this a n plus
one if this value is greater than the
old value and you you toss it away if it
isn't and so you and you randomly sample
each of these these new genes from some
fixed underlying
distribution so the the situation we're
considering is where you have in this
multi-dimensional space some Global
Optimum but your variation is
constrained in that this this Matrix a
is not full Rank and so you can only go
to this constrained Optimum and then you
add new vectors pointing in various
directions and if you go immediately go
uphill you keep that vector and if you
don't go uphill you get rid of it so
here's you get out of evolving genomes
through this process so
um so here this is a as you're starting
with a genome of size zero and you're
adding genes up to size 32 and these are
your departures from optimality for each
of these different
indices and for here for comparison is
what you would get if you if you kept
all the new genes that were added to the
genome and didn't filter it by based on
whether they produced an immediate
selective advantage and what you see
here is that um some of these Fitness
components they never get very small
they never get very good so this is far
from Optimum whereas here the all of
them get very good and in a much faster
time so if we look at the um the
distance from the
optimum and so this is basically this is
our genome growth model where you only
keep the gene if it produces an
advantage immediately and here where you
keep all the genes this reflects the
underlying distribution of the sampling
of the gene effects and you see that the
adapt adaptation is much faster with a
smaller number of smaller genome
size under a more natural uh uh natural
model of genome growth than on the
underlying distribution of genes that
are sampled and so basically at 32 genes
you're about this level and you get
there with this you know something like
five genes when you're when the gene was
kept only if it produced intermediate
advantage and so you in a sense you get
a more compact representation of this
Fitness
Optimum now the second model I want to
do is using calin's NK
model so here the idea is you have a set
of Fitness functions you have a set of
genes and given Gene affects some subset
of these Fitness functions and then you
add a new Gene to the genome with some
random set of Fitness functions that
it's
altering and um and then here's the the
fitness of this is equal to the sum or
the average of these different Fitness
functions but the the essence of
cowman's uh model is that anytime you
change an Al of any of the genes
affecting this Fitness function that it
gets resampled from the same underlying
distribution of Fitness values so that's
actually kingman's house of cards model
and so when you add a new Gene if it if
it affects 53 basically that means you
resample fitness component three from
some underlying distribution and the
same here with Fitness six and it leaves
the rest of them
alone now
um so let's imagine so here we are
adding genes to the genome and now a new
Gene Alters these these Fitness
functions of these dark spots say
they're K of them what's the probability
that that new Gene uh will produce a
fitness increase when added and so here
is a a graph showing that relationship
in terms of the number of genes that it
affects at versus the the old Fitness
and here is the um uh the probability
that the new fitness is greater than the
old and as you can see the greater the
the old Fitness is the less the
probability that you can randomly
increase it through this peration and
also the greater the number of these
Fitness functions that are perturbed the
smaller the probability that you can
increase it and so again using this
genome growth Dynamic you can build up
the genes and the genome and so this
this is a kind of the null model and
this is the underlying distribution of
ply tropy effects as you add new genes
The genome so this is the random sample
that we're select that we're drawing
from but we here's the The genome that
you get when you only keep the gene if
it produces a fitness advantage and what
you see as adaptation as genome as the
gene size uh increases as the genome
size increases and you add more and more
genes it filters it to have effect on
fewer and fewer of these functions and
so by the time you get to Gene 30 it
only affects one of those functions and
so what's happening is that as the as
the organism gets more and more adapted
you have to have few you have to have
smaller and smaller ply tropy to be able
to get into the genome and here you can
look at the average p tropy as the gene
number goes up and it starts out here
and it gets smaller and smaller and
smaller and so we can actually look at
the distribution so here's the the
random sample that we're sampling from
but here it is in the actual genome that
evolves through this
process and here if you look at the
actual the
Landscapes from this
process uh you see even more remarkable
properties so what we've done is taken
um the landc taken these genotypes that
evolved and then done a random initial
search uh started them randomly and let
them evolve to a fitness Peak and these
this is the distribution of the fitness
Peak sorted
and so
our more realistically evolved genomes
have these large attractors to the
fitness these Fitness Peaks and they're
completely out of the range of what you
get from generic
Landscapes and um and this again shows
the distribution of Fitness effects from
our generic Landscapes versus the ones
that are actually evolved and they're
they're not even
overlapping so um to conclude we we've
seen some of the early history and
continuing controversy about the
evolution of evolvability and I've
described a general mechanism by which
evolvability can evolve through
individual selection and the mechanism
occurs to the relationships between the
distribution of Fitness effects of a
gene origin of it subsequent alic
variation and subsequent Gene
duplication and the mechanism I
Illustrated with a simple but General
mathematical model with a price equation
and the vogner's B matrix model a real
Vector genotype phenotype maps and
calin's NK model of discreet genotype
phenotype
maps and uh I've attempted to show how
Gene Origins can shape the distribution
of Fitness effects of both Gene
duplication and AIC variation now here's
a quote from a a reviewer From Evolution
he says why such selection is a means by
which selection can come to ACT
indirectly on evolutionary potential is
beyond my understanding well I hope my
presentation has been clearer to you
than it was for that reviewer and uh
details can be found in this paper and
so um if these ideas have piqued your
interest I welcome theoretical and
empirical collaborations and I thank you
for your
attention any questions